Maybe. Probably for a little
bit. Target down. 5 hours. Get
to work. Little 5 hours just.
Incoming.
Little grind going.
there we go. Kills, boom.
Feel so fast.
Did he
fix the input leg?
Hm.
So thank you very much. Yeah,
I'm still playing Cuba Mouse.
Of course, of course me.
Still playing that keyboard,
mouse, vibe.
I'm going to go back honestly.
Go back over here.
You got gas moving in. Enemy
UAV overhead. Wait. Wait, why
in the public event are open?
We got another one. On the
ground.
This is the gulag. In here, you
fight to win back your life.
Dead soldiers, I offer you a
life for a Can those across
from you and I will return you
to your weapon
Why does that bug, bro? I can
Alright, come on boss. Got it.
**** you, he said.
Nobody. Let's go. Dump.
play.
That guy
He's ****
or else
He's fake. In the area.
Hostile, UAV in the air, yo.
What are you selling me, bro? I
really wish I had bird eye view
right now.
Gas is inbound. Marking new
safe zone.
I don't know where the
strongholds were, bro.
Dang.
Enemy UAV active. Every time.
Another guy on me.
I hurt you. Would you like to
be friends?
Marking enemy.
Moving here.
Moving
here.
Marking enemy.
Look at Papa's. This guy's
tired.
What the ****
Oh my god. I'm going to shot
from every single angle. Holy
****
Enemy UAV overhead.
Like, come on. Where's the
audio? We will settle the
score. **** me, bro. I don't
see him. I'm blind. I'm just
**** blind. That's what it is.
What's up, Doc?
is stupid
Um
It sucks. Music
I got, no, music. Why does my
break like not work, bro? on my
chrome crash knives.
Yes, it can be, bro.
Uh huh.
It completes crash or something
like closed program.
Reopen.
Yo, Jack, you do me a favor.
Smash that, like, our reaction.
Would you please watch your
code? What'd you coach your
code? The first game on. That
was stupid. I don't hear
himself Rez and he has. Bro. I
hate it. I hate it here.
Honestly, I hate here.
Hi, Eddie
Check weapons and gear. We're
holding for deployment.
Hostile dropping into the area.
Watch the skies.
Whoa.
Hello.
Practice is over. The real
fight begins now.
Avoid the gas. Get to the safe
zone. into the AO.
Eliminate all targets in the A
What's up, buddy?
Bye bye. We should have popped
it for this bud. The hell the
homies for then.
Yo, what up, Amber?
Yo, Chad, if you're just
shooting in, hit that like high
reaction. Come on now. Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh,
Come on. I'll break it. Need a
couple dollars, man. A couple
dollars, eh? It's a couple.
Anyone leave some cash on the
kitchen tablet for my lunch or
what? Enemy UAV active. Like
that, huh? No, bro. Bro. ****
off.
**** don't **** giggle at me.
I'll show you my freaking piss.
I know karate.
But there's a ladder to this
upstairs. I did not know that.
It's crazy. I know karate.
Don't make me come out there. I
will. UAV in the area. Hey, how
many of those you got? Can I
have one?
Enemy UAV overhead.
Enemy UAV active. My god.
Are
UAV sale or something?
Bro, give me a goddamn ****
**** dude. flock.
Yo, cover your mouth when you
cough, bro.
Calm down, buddy. I've had it
twice. Oh, **** My mom just got
it. I'm about to get it again.
Was it worse the second time or
no? I didn't lose my taste. Oh,
so you had, ooh.
Wanna be friends? We gotta
conquer Al Mazra together.
I'm guessing. I don't know. It
might be very positive ID on
multiple strongholds. What?
Locations are marked on your
attack map. Dude, do you need a
halt? I got a halt in my
pocket. Wanna try the **** RPK
out this game so
You want to try my Rowl? Dude,
you should try the Rowl. Where
are you? Do what? I I'll show
you my row. Dude, you, I think
you'll like the row more than
the RPK. Where you, where you
at? Where you at? Shoot one
bullet. I'll come to you. We'll
get two load outs. We'll get
two guns and then we'll try
guns. And I'll show you the the
the rail capability. That's? Oh
****
I'm guessing that. Okay, you
and quiet. Okay, I guess you
don't want to. Okay. Whatever.
Search yourself.
I'll just go by my own gun. Did
you get a haircut? No. I need
one. You know any hair cutters?
Hey. Stop selfing. Or I will
kill you. I need.
He didn't listen.
No, I can't ball that guy.
Shoot. Listen, I I don't want
that. I'm good. I'm good. I'm
good. I'm good. I'm good.
I guess I'm good.
Hello.
Anybody home?
Collect my reward. Oh, don't
mind if I do.
That could've been bad.
and he was a sinner, dude.
Gas is closing. Get to the new
safe zone.
Wow.
I was the guy who turned around
and killed him.
Whatcha doing? On that balcony,
huh? What you doing? Oh. Oh,
did you feel the whiff of the
bullet by side of your face?
Moving here. Did you like it?
Would you like to be friend?
Oh, oh, sorry. Oh, dude.
Listen.
We can talk about this, bro.
The **** is a circus?
You got another self. Listen.
You got another one? You do.
Okay. Listen. Listen. Okay.
Okay. Listen. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. Listen. Listen.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Okay. We can
talk about this. You get up,
Drop your money. I'll let you
live. But you do any funny
business. The thing you
surround me, I'm going to throw
at you. Understand? Kamprende?
Okay. I trust you. Now, what
gun do you have? What gun do
you got? What? Mm, a nice oh,
you got platinum, dude? Holy
**** You, you're kind of
goaded. Oh my god. What the,
what
Here you go. I feel kind of
bad. but like you can Hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, put that gun
away. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey. Hey. Look at, look at the
window. Hey, look at the
window. Look at, hey, turn
around. Look at the window.
Alright, bye. Okay.
There's another idiot here.
Hold on. I gotta I gotta kill
him. He didn't have a self
though. He kind of just died.
Look at that. Hey, here's Lou.
Yo, buddy. Hi, his loot's right
here. You can come get it. Come
get it. Right here. I'll shoot
once. Come get his loot.
Yeah, like a whole thirty bucks
in there. A whole 30 bucks.
Come here. Wait, can I see your
Mfour? Can I see your Mfour?
Can you drop it? **** Check out
my route. Dude, you'll like
this thing. You know what?
You'll like that. Trust me.
Shoot that thing. Yeah, you
like that, don't you? Mm hmm.
Air Force not bad. You know,
not bad. I like your skin.
Nice.
Wait. Wait, I can't drop your
gun. Oh, there we go. Okay.
Alright.
What Hurricane? Ooh, I don't
have my SMGs. So,
It's okay. Alright, alright,
alright. I'm fine right here.
Wait, you want my route? Well,
you can I have my row back
then? Okay. That's all I have
is a mini back.
What?
Shoot it? You want me shoot it?
New safe zone located. Wait,
wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait,
wait
relude. Alright, see you later.
It doesn't **** move. I like
it. Here. Take it back.
Are you good? You gotta load
out. Drop inbound. Alright.
I'll see you in that game.
Adios amigo. Adios.
All stations. Is active That
guy has come back again. Wait.
Oh, never mind. I thought we
could kill a dagger.
Dude, he has a freaking
hurricane that doesn't. What
the **** I kind of sick. No
cap.
That's how you make a friend,
Chat. That's how you make a
friend. I don't even know what
his name is.
Mm hmm. My fire.
Yeah, let's run some souls.
Tell me why.
No one? Okay.
Yo, what's up Eric? How we
doing? What's good? What's
good? What's up, brother? Open
door.
I need to get away from the sky
behind me. Am I shooting the
butt? Ooh. Thank you for
popping the UAV for me. I
appreciate it my guy.
I don't know.
Oopsie, did I throw that? My
bad. Did it hurt a little?
precision airstrike. Find
cover.
Whoa. Wait. Wait. Don't self.
Don't self. Don't self. Stop
selfie girl. I'll kill you.
Never mind. They'll never
learn.
Alright, hello. I'm here for
your cars extend warranty
payment. I know you're in the
building beside me. One one
requesting recon at this time.
Oh, we got UAV online and
opting the AO.
Scag, I, I need you. Um, I'm
here for your cars instead of
warranty payment. Uh no hablo?
Español? Uh poor for a plateau.
Uh C senior. Latin. I need
plateau. Bingo fuel. RTV. Give
me plateau. I'll let you live.
I got gas moving in. I got
plateau? Or vat? or do I let
you die? I need two plateau.
Yes. Anitos Plato.
Four four four. Yes.
Toss Plateau, you make me live,
I let you live or Portos
Plateau, I had to kill. You
pick. Hold on.
come to the parking garage
right now. Come here. No
gracias. No, Eno. Gracias. You
gracias. Now, come here. Enemy,
UAV overhead.
Listen, I knew, I know one
Spanish word, okay? Ready for
it? No, not not Benteo. No, no,
no, no, I know that too but
now, Ron. Puta? Avron. Tavron.
See? Si. Si amigo. That's a
scoot. That what does it mean?
Doesn't mean **** That's as
good or that's German, brother.
That way, hold on. I'm going to
get bamboozled here. Yo, Noah,
it's my friend. No. Yolo. I
just killed my boy. Oh, dude. I
made friends with this guy. Me
and him had a good time. He
gave me his gun to try out and
I gave him my gun to try out.
Now, it's a ghost town. It's
really cool. You know I know
where you are, right? I'm I
need you to know that I need to
kill you but we could be
friends and we can get the dub
together. What what are you
thinking? Oh, sure.
Alright, now get out of Burger
King. Come here. Will Hung.
Come here. What do you need?
Get out of the burger. Go to
the blue car with the hood up.
Burger King? I don't. Yeah,
dude. You're trolling amigo.
You're trolling. Gracias,
amigo.
I really don't know what the
**** I'm saying.
All I know is that you need to
come out with your hands up.
Out of the Burger King because
Burger King is closed. No more
Whopper for you.
You gotta come out, dude. The
zone's here, buddy. We gotta
go. Come on. Let's go. Focus
up. Come on. Come on out. I'll
let you live. I'll let you
live. Dude, I'm actually not
even trolling. Why are you
trolling, bro? I see you. I see
you, dude. Like, I'm kind of
miss you but like, you're like
running away from me and I do
not like it, okay, buddy? You
have abandonment issues? I am
literally abandoning you
because you keep running.
Marking enemy.
Did it hurt?
Yo, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, chill, chill, chill,
boys, boys. There's two of you.
Listen. We all could form
alliance here.
strike in the area. Hey.
Something a **** would say. Yo,
Jay, listen. You want to take
over the world together?
We could be friends, amigo.
Amigo. Four for four. Friendo.
Amigo. Gracias.
10 remain. You're nearly done.
What the **** are you doing?
I'm just sitting there bro. Oh
my god. Bro. No, dude. You're
trolling. Let me just see the
corner, bro. I saw his ****
footstep, dude. No. Sounds like
a **** would say.
You're so funny, bro.
No. Yo, Chad, if you're liking
the content, hit that like,
heart reaction. We're going to
get back in it. Back in it.
We're going to go back in. Back
in. Back in.
Holding for deployment. Take
this time to warm up. Just
purchase a house? Oh my god,
Eric. Let's go. Let's go.
Hey. See that you're in my
office. Would you like to
dropping into the area? Excuse
me? Right here, this is a Call
of Duty Service right here. Um
they're not kind of plugged in
right now. As you can tell by
the leg in the Devars. Yeah,
sooner or later, we'll plug
those in. Warm up is over.
Again. Stand by for deployment.
Set up.
seconds. Good luck down there.
Gas is closing on your
position. Suggest you get
moving.
targets.
Hostile UAV in the area.
P Diddy.
One one requesting recon at
this time. Copy. UAV station.
Recon online.
UAV is bingo fuel. RTV at this
time.
Enemy UAV active.
I'm the Scatman.
I'm staying in a game chat too,
Chad. Waiting for someone to
start seeing a bag.
Enemy UAV overhead.
Clear now. He's a weird
He's a weirdo. Oh, hello.
Hostile dropping into the area.
Watch the skies. Awesome idea.
Don't do it. Don't do it. Okay,
you're proning on that roof
doesn't help either. You just
gotta go. I see you, buddy.
It's, come on. Jump up. There's
a guy below you. Yeah, careful.
Careful.
Boy, listen. You gotta get off,
dude. I'll shoot you until you
get off. Be advised. Intel has
located multiple
I'm behind the **** wall. I'm
Batman.
You know, Virtual wanted to
play. What's today?
Use this time to practice. We
will be deploying soon.
What the ****
Hello.
She think I'm cute. She want to
What's up bro?
Enough training. Now, we face
the enemy for real.
Jump in a better place this
time
this surround pass Five seconds
to the release point
One, two, one.
Be advised. Gas is closing in.
Moving here. Yeah, boy.
Hunch the enemy down.
Talking about some yeah boy.
Probably three. But I see.
trust them here for. Oh. I'm
just scared, man
Two down. Secure the last safe.
We got that whole ****
All safes have been secured. I
mean, it's there, bro. Fight
me, bro. What is this ****
Targets are marked under attack
map.
It's another John over his
song. Hold on. Right there.
Yeah, we in the safe zone.
Hostile cluster 9 active. Bro,
what the ****
**** back up.
Some of your team is still
Friendly UAV on station.
located high value equipment.
Enemy containers. Move in and
secure that equipment
That's two down. One safe to
go.
effective fire. the gulag. You
have to fight to earn
redeployment. How? With us,
man. Come on, man. Hold up.
What you doing? One V three.
Well, you guys are **** looting
similar.
Hey, we we just trying to do
that with a D, right? For ****
you know what I'm saying? Like,
we ain't trying to go here
first and **** We just trying
to be right for **** You know
what I'm saying?
I get shy. I got **** I get
**** Yeah, I mean, I do gotta
get on your **** because you
just try to go hard on me like
you just got five, six, 7,
eight. Turn up. Turn up.
Listen, listen. Tater, tighter
**** over the **** Yeah.
here to escape
Okay, Helix. Come on, baby.
Hey, son.
Oh, boy. Dude, okay. I don't
like the person at all.
Dude, why did Ames say trios?
Why is this triggering my fight
or flight reflex?
Warm up while you can. We will
deploy soon.
Training is over. Time to see
what you have learned.
5 seconds to jump.
for your squad. You will lead
them in
The act is approaching your
position. I'm a Batman.
Marking contract.
Primary objective is to
eliminate all targets. Bro, get
me off the ladder, please.
Why is there like never a gun
in these buildings, bro? Get a
gun. An enemy squad is hunted.
Come on. Stay alert. Whoa.
Wanna play a game?
But what is wrong with the
scheme?
Enemy UAV active.
This is computer.
Yeah, that makes sense. Thank
you. For your chance to
redeploy.
No sense, bro.
I'm a Scatman.
I offer you a life for a Can
those across from you and I
will return you to you or kill
your way
Positive ID on multiple
strongholds. Locations are
marked on your attack map.
Intel located enemy retainers
holding high-value equipment.
Secure the content.
You've got one safe open. Two
to go. Oh, there's another one
be huge.
Yeah.
You have one safe remaining.
Get moving.
One one requesting recon at
this time. Copy that.
What the ****
is bingo fuel. RTV at this
time.
How about this gun, bro?
One one requesting recon at
this time. Copy that. UAV
online and AO.
New safe zone located.
Like, how does he
I need a. It's just not
going to work. I mean,
everyone's using this because
they have an assist. There's
only **** reason why they use
it. I kind of gotta see what I.
did you fry me from?
I don't have some **** bro. I
gotta
Stronghold, bro. It was on the
roof right now.
You fought hard out there.
Return to base for debris.
Requested fire mission.
Let's try that, bro.
Are
I need to find a gun that
works, bro.
Let's just let's just do this
too. Um, bod, bod, bod, bod,
bot, bod,
build
her neck.
Bennett.
Wait, what is it?
Don't have it. God dang it. 90
bro. What does this do?
Vertical recoil.
It's just a castle comp.
Nothing laser.
Okay.
Like why is my arm not working?
What the ****
Titans. Still same stock. 4five
and Sharkfin, I'm guessing.
To the end. Okay, guys. So, to
start this regain, you guys
want to come to L, Sherim Pass.
When it comes to this first
pool of water, grab the first
Lucash. See you guys at 500
cash and Mfour and a kill
streak. And what you guys
want to do from here is you
want to follow the river to the
next pool of water. This will
then lead you to your second
loot cash, 3, 500 cash, a war
machine, and a kill streak. And
then once you get out of this
pool of water, you want to keep
running in this direction. You
want to fly off this cliff. and
here you will have your third
loot cash. 3, 500 cash and
armor satchel and a water
strike. Yo, yo, yo, what's
going on, guys? What was here?
Here's a crazy, good regain
spot over at Warzone two point
oh. This could give you crazy
kill streaks, cash, and
weapons.
Use this time to practice. We
will be deploying soon.
Seems like a macro, bro.
I'm a macro.
Enemy soldier incoming. Nice.
Enough training. Now, we face
the enemy for real.
honestly
Those suckers. 5 seconds.
Standby to deploy.
Avoid the gas. Get to the safe
zone.
Marking contract.
Eliminate all targets in the
AO.
Enemy base holding high-value
equipment have been located.
Secure on
Hostile dropping into the area.
Watch the skies.
What?
This is strong. I could stay
around. Enemy UAV overhead.
****
You've got two down. One safe
to go.
Hostile UAV in the area.
side. side. side. Has located
multiple strongholds.
Bro.
One one. Requesting recon at
this time. Copy that. UAV
online and opting the AO.
I don't know about it anymore.
Be advised, UAV is exiting the
AO.
no ****
Like
We got another one. On the
ground.
This is the gulag. Bro.
Redeployment. Fun, dude.
There's no audio on that guy
walking up on me. Can I get
something, please? Like, what
the **** What's my audio, dude?
I swear. Head soldiers. I offer
and I will return you to your
I'm **** behind the wall.
And then my teammate throws a
nade and it shows that it's
mine. What?
Damon's **** goat
I got someone joining right
over here But next time for
sure. Disposal. A charge was
sent in the
Failure is a
they should.
That's funny.
What is that? That's a that's a
controller. Badly in need of
being charged right there. Oh
my. I need to find this player.
I need to find this player
Please
for the love of God let
us proud to be on them. They
must be nearby. Oh my God. That
is so loud.
Warm up while you can. We will
deploy soon.
Enemy soldier incoming
Practice is over. The real
fight begins now.
Yo, what's up, Freeman? Closing
in. Proceed to the safe zone.
What's good? Twitter. Did did
you know that they're making a
Transformers movie?
But no no.
Fight the enemy down. Enemy
dropping into the AO.
I know I watched the previous
yet. No. I just saw it on
Twitter. I was watching right
now but. Holding high-value
equipment. Need audio.
Copyright. You can't do it.
what the **** Yo. chill, dog.
What the **** dude? I'm just
**** looting. Leave me alone.
**** bot. Don't make me come
over there and **** on you.
Let's play soon. Yeah, for
sure, man. Let me know. Oh, let
me know. Let me know. Maybe
this weekend. Alright, Bird
Dash Weekend. Imperial Freaker.
Oh, I got this. Yo, bro.
Listen. I'm just trying to ****
get a plate, dog. And my guns.
eighty-eight.
Hostiles dropping into the area
Enemy UAV overhead.
Hostile UAV in the area.
The wrong building, buddy.
You've opened this. Don't mind
me. I'm just doing my safes.
Oh, nothing to see here.
Hey, bro. Listen. I'm just
doing my saves, man. Holy ****
bro. Listen. You know how to be
so feisty. Targets are marked
under attack map.
While I wait for you to come.
and the Samsung doesn't go to
the wall yet
Enemy dropping into the AO. My
second chance at last and you
won't kill.
you are
fire
the one
desire
And yeah.
Get off the roof. No.
You are. Is Mike just mic on
the whole time?
Mark, bro.
**** Oh. **** **** **** ****
**** **** **** **** **** I got
shot at. I'm scared. Hey, help
me. Time's expired.
Bro, give me some dark goddamn
kiss, bro. He summoned that
goddamn Anyone got some cash,
bro? I just need a couple for
my gun, bro. I'll pay you back.
Hey, what's going up there?
Hey, well, do you shot me, bro?
What the, what the weird
friends? I thought we could be
friends, bro.
Oh yeah, I switched it. We
friends, bro. Listen. You, me,
you and me. Baby, please.
Nothing but mammals. So, let's
do it. Do it on Discovery
Channel. duplicate now.
You guys not a part of that
vibe?
Georgie
now, you In the new safe zone.
So let's do it like we do it on
Discovery Channel. Bam, bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam,
bam, bam, hello. Why guys have
gone quiet?
I got Fitbit. It's your turn,
buddy. How would you like to
die today?
Get back, guys. My god, you
little rat, bro. You little
rat. That's all I have to say.
You, you, you got some cheese
in there? Are you stacking?
Gas is inbounded.
No plates, bro? Come on, bro.
I
think it was a **** bot. Oh.
That's how the way by he move.
He's a little Botsky.
Little easy work for the funny.
gang. I got no selfies for the
**** world, dawg.
I would like. I do like
spraying this.
Do it again now.
Wow.
I'm driving. I'll use that to
my advantage.
The disease iron.
Oh, man. This site sucks, bro.
They're like a two and a half
optic. Is there a two and a
half optic that doesn't **** Or
look.
I wanted like a three-yard X.
whatever this one is, three
point four. Yeah, it's inbound.
Marking new safe zone. Get two
point seven. Maybe, maybe a
three solid Four is too much.
Enemy squad is tracking your
position. Alright. Load and
drop headed your way.
Really? All the load ups on the
other side of the water.
Moving here.
Enemy UAV active.
Gas is closing in. Relocating
the safe zone.
Moving here.
****
What? How did he? Did the car
take him with them? Like, what
the ****
You like it? You like you have
to reload, you idiot.
Excuse me?
There is no way you're telling
me my bullets just stop
registering right there. That's
crazy. Who would have thought?
Bro.
Moving here.
there's
a person in there.
You've got gas inbound. Marking
grenade
****
Moving here.
Oh, we'll get stuck on him.
He's getting stuck on
everything. Why don't you? Save
zone
For **** sakes, bro. Look, why
did I get stuck in this? Look
at this, bro. I get stuck.
Please **** watch out and Bro,
that's so **** cringe, bro. I
took this **** game, man. I get
stuck and I get pelted because
of it.
Oh my god, dude. Okay. So, that
optic sucked in there. I want a
better optic, bro. This optic
is **** Like you don't even
tell me the range, bro. Mm.
Hop in there real quick.
What the heck? ah
check your gear and weapons. We
go
What the ****
Tell me why ain't nothing but
I dabbed. Oh, maybe not.
Alright.
They won Holland.
Use this time to practice. We
will be deploying soon
Hostile dropping into the area.
Watch the skies.
Warm up is over. Stand by for
deployment to the war zone.
Avoid the gap. Get to the safe
zone
Eliminate all targets in the A
high-value equipment in enemy
containers. Move in and secure
that equipment.
Pro, dude. This game is so
tough. Yeah, this is.
Looks like we got another one.
On the ground. Fight for your
chance to redeploy
So does home.
boy. Soldiers
last two standing were leader
will rise soon.
Just wasted all my time.
Advise for redeployment.
Hey.
Dude, what?
Positive ID on multiple
Locations are marked on your
attack map.
Enemy, UAV, overhead.
Be advised.
Enemy dropping into the AO. He
was like, what the **** Learn
from the lost. Failure is a
wise teacher.
Oh my god, dude. I just want to
play with it. I can't do solos,
man. I'm losing my mind
do not want to play dude but
like
Two **** hours, bro.
Don't say noone on. I'm
learning the one plane.
There's noone on, man.
and thirteen. What did you say?
You have to be a certain right
to use Bitten thirteen. You
actually have to get it through
DMZ but I can I can get it for
you in a cheap. But everyone
says that it's
Oh, nice play, dude. It was
incredibly decentky. He sorted
it wrong here. Okay, he got
this thing. Uh. Yeah, good
player. Very, very desyncy for
some reason in solos. I don't
know how much knee he has.
It looked like he prefired the
No one on, man.
No **** on, bro. At home, I
still listen to murdered.
Oh, boy.
Just one glass
Check your gear and weapons. We
go soon
Preparation is done. Now, you
deploy to the war zone.
dumping fire. Get ready.
Jazz is closing on your
position. Suggest you get
moving
Primary objective is to
eliminate all
That could've been bad.
Will they patch this? it. This
one. I patched it.
Oh my god, they patched it.
Heal.
Look, **** we got another one.
This is a gulag. You'll have to
fight to earn redeployment.
Dead soldiers, I offer you a
life for a life youth and I
will return you to your will
My team is **** dumbest. Oh my
god. I'm getting off, dude. I
swear to god, I'm going to get
off.
so locked in on my homework I
feel bad. Now, I'll make it up
and we'll play like like three
hours That sounds like fun. I'm
really losing it but are you
on? How long have you been
playing? **** vlog. I log on
your **** and you were ****
playing for a long time
already. I'm so fine. I'm
really annoyed. Those are mean
fun, bro. I can never make it
fun. So bad. Just everyone is
singing corners, bro. When's
trios coming out? That's what I
really want to play. or I think
I'll join you Mario. There you
go.
Uh I'm going to play. We
want to play duos. Trios or
quets. Not up to you. Whatever
you're in the mood for.
I mean, is he, he can handle he
can handle quads or what? We're
just running together. Do you
know who I am? You referred
will
Virtual. Are you serious right
now? You better turn the ****
up then. Are you playing on
controller or let me get? Oh,
hell no, bro. I was going to
play on controller but like, I
just don't have a scuff and I
just don't want to buy money
for a scuff so. Well, I bought
a $500 aim controller and it
broke. What? It broke? Yeah.
How the **** did you, how did
**** you break on? You **** sit
on that? No, bro. It, so I was
playing, so I, I have a, those
control freak things on. Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah. and I guess
when I push forward, there's
enough pressure where it broke.
No. Where the. From the analog
stick? Like, not the whole
stick, just like the piece
where is it? The removable,
right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh huh. So, like, you know
where you untake it out? That
little like hexagon piece, like
one of the sides broke. What
the **** Yeah, I don't know.
And they won't like replace it
for you. I'm just going to work
here. Yeah, no, I got, I got
unlimited warrant. I got, I
just send it there and they'll
fix it but **** That ****
sucks. What the **** I mean, I
was going to then I had
another. Go crazy on
controller. Oh, James. This is
insane, dude. I know the, the
game is 10 times harder without
like the back, back pedals. Or
what? And you can't jump. Cuz
then you can't jump, right?
Like I'm playing club but it's
even harder to jump. Jumping's
literally all just **** warzone
is so.
Warzone. Now, Warzone two is
only worth jumping. Get nothing
out of it. Yeah, it's true.
Yeah, luckily, I've been just
**** I've been just grinding
all these **** guns I want.
Like, this raw I have is ****
disgusting, dude. It's so dumb.
I'm on the right optic on it,
bro.
I
took the MOP bro. I don't use
but Yeah, the MOP. I **** with
the MOP. Yeah, but you can't
see anything in a distance,
bro. Right when you start
shooting, you lose someone's
crushing. You do, no? What else
is a good slagger, right? The
slagger is good, right? But I
have one right now. Trying it.
I tried the other one. The
three point seven. Too much
visual recoil. I don't know. I
saw something online where it
said like close. It's supposed
to be better than far, right?
Or some **** like that? I don't
know. I saw some **** article
on it. Just zooms in. There's
more zoo Oh, god. We got two
**** idiots with us. Alright,
we'll just, and like we know
So, what you've been doing?
Just warzone? Called you?
Warzone. Warzone. Warzone. Call
of Duty. More warzone? Yeah.
All you could play on Facebook.
Really? They're like the only
popular game on Facebook? Yeah.
Oh, there's not really much
else. So, Doc's here. This
game's not too hot. This game
is actually pretty fun though.
Okay, dude. Listen. Did you
play warzone at all? No, no. I
I didn't play the end towards
warzone. I only played I just
enjoyed this too. Like there's
so many things you can do in
Warzone. One that you can't do
unless you like like you know
when you play in this game. Uh
yeah yeah they usually have
momentum right? Yeah there's
**** nothing. And then when you
jump you lose all your
momentum. Like what is this? I
tried to jump across a roof and
I lose all my movement. I'm
going to pull my parachute.
Yeah like I don't I don't like
hate that there's not like ****
nerd movement gamers now right?
Like but just **** I think the
slide is useless. The slide is
useless. Kinda **** Well, the
dolphin dive is good. So, if
you're on the lower. Terrible.
If you're on a lower ledge, you
could dolphin dive off and pull
your chute instantly and you
you go across the ledges really
fast. Um Like like clefts and
**** You can you can pull your
**** better. I don't know.
That's the only good thing I
found about dolphin diving.
Maybe dolphin diving a cover
maybe. But. Yeah it's good for
like if I'm trying to like
rotate through somewhere and
there's just a **** sniper
sitting somewhere. Gonna just
fall and dive everywhere.
You ping this?
For your squad, soldier.
Alright. Let's go where they
go, I guess. closing in. That's
shot.
Watch the sky.
I just look straight down at
the floor.
There's a lot of people. ****
Don't, I will go live. We'll go
live to the left. Yeah, I'm
going to say.
clear to engage all targets.
The **** LGs. Okay.
I don't know. I feel like this
**** three-play **** where you
have to really grab one. I
don't know. You get ****
shredded if you don't have one.
Well, the TTK and regular,
regular warzone was a while.
Lots slower. If they survive,
they reject. Yeah, yeah. Yeah,
there's a three plane in here
if you want it.
He might butt.
entered the gulag. Surviving
earns and redeployment. Square
meters enter the gulag. I died
the but we moved it into the
Finally, quads, bro. I can
actually read what they do.
Holy **** So, they just sit
corners and they remove. Yo,
squadmate was broken. Oh, solos
is actually.
I never like playing Battle
Royale so
redeployment. I'm going to try
solo duos. It was even more
terrible. There's just two of
them in the window. **** did it
one? There's two. I want to
play trios but then everyone's
like a six man so like no. I
want to do that. Yeah, I know.
Yeah. Once a normal **** trio's
coming out, bro. for the people
that couldn't find a fourth.
Yeah, I know. Usually, I just
play with like, I have like
three friends that like to play
so. My friends get like ****
terrible frames in this game.
They have like a 2062 so I was
like just surprised. It's so
bad. They're like running
twenty-four or like **** forty
frames. What?
Dude, I have a twelve nine
hundred K with the 3080 TI and
I still get horrible frames.
Yeah, I have a thirty. And I'm
on right now. And I'm on a dual
PC setup. Oh, you're dual
streaming too? Yeah, I was
about to say if you're not,
then, this probably even worse,
right? Bro. I don't even think
it's possible to play this game
ever streaming.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Have you
noticed the mouse symbol like?
No, not really. That was a lot.
I mean, like, I don't know. My
my sense in this game never
feels like right. It always
kind of changes. Always feels
like **** There you go, the
strong Where is it? Let's go
Hook me up with cash.
Yeah, I know. I've I've played
I played the ****
Floyd back. Hook me up with
cash.
You know, I'll drop it to him.
Here we go. Got cash here. I
got played I think the
beginning of the multiplayer
like in the. Moving. And not
like beta but I think like the
early access stage and that's
the game I I literally cannot
play this game. This game is
**** terrible. It was really
**** bad. What the. Like just
the beginning. Like I think
before they nerfed all these
**** guns. I like I I I was not
having fun at all over here.
Not even cool of it.
From disposal. A charge over
there. What the ****
I mean it's **** other
Getting **** Bro, how many
kills do I have to? Alright,
wait, hold on. Let me, let me,
let me take all my Oh my god.
**** grenade, dude. Are you
trolling? I just chucked that
**** back. No, no, no, no, no,
this is actually ridiculous.
I'm going in. I'm going. Oh my
god. Fire. They **** beamed
too. No, no, no, no, no. I
don't want to, I don't want to
play this game. Hurry in, bro.
I'm just coming to you. Yeah,
I'm just diffusing this ****
bro. Jesus Christ, man.
There's a team here, I guess.
What is there? I know. Ammo
here. Black Move to that
location. More intent to
follow. UAV active
I think they have a load out.
What the **** happened to you?
I I don't know. I shot a one
through the window and
instantly died.
Drop them.
I'm just going to line back
down and just **** pray bro.
Just go with your load. You're
probably going to win the
building. I mean, he's probably
in the building. Yeah I don't
know bro but I'm **** going in
this **** I don't care. That's
you **** **** bro.
Give me the **** out. ****
leave this game now. **** idiot
is sitting in the **** right
corner with them. **** fenick.
Their death is so dumb. Oh my
god, they have my Ryan. They
have Orion on all their guns.
Your squad is KIA. It is up to
you. Dude, are you ****
serious? What? Why am I
playing? What? What? You like
my ice cream, ma'am? Fun as
hell. Oh, yeah. This is a lot
of fun. Mm hmm.
I I literally like peeked out
the window and I think all four
of them shot at me. More than
my SPMM where it's terrible.
I'm too used to playing with my
brother. I gotta **** like lock
in or some **** You gotta
realize that they shoot faster
than you can shoot. They're
don't no matter. They got 16
scoops of G film. And they got
a controller too.
so they don't miss and if they
do miss, it's because they
didn't get aim assist and oh,
what a great game.
Jesus bro. It was fun.
among steroids, monitoring
meds, I train
or kiss
Up, Kanye Garband again. Bye
bye. I'm not surprised, bro. I
mean, I like, I love Kanye and
I **** love all his music but
like, Jesus Christ. They're so
stupid. I love Hitler. Like I
didn't wake up until like 2 PM
this morning. So I like looked
at my phone and the first thing
I see is **** Kanye West
running. I was like oh God. Not
again.
Warm up while you can. We will
deploy soon.
Okay. He dropped the, do we
drop the news yet? I don't
know. No I keep crashing.
Crashing, bro. We did it like,
we did like four days in a row.
Four different days. We had
like 13 wins. Oh. No. ****
Fifth, fifth, 15, what was it?
It was 13 wins every every day.
We go for 4 days. We dev aired
every fifth game and every time
we got in a new contract. No.
Jeez. I was just stopped
drawing. That's so dumb, bro.
Whoever called me out of the
pregame, come get the smoke. I
love what Brock has reminds me
of each one so **** Uh huh.
bro. I don't really have a
go-to spot to get on this ****
map. It's like everywhere
that's like inoculated. Never
**** has anybody. I swear to
Christ
Let's take the job.
I feel like our teammates
kind of know what they're doing
Seems like a driver. Oh,
there's two people on him. I'm
not landing on them. Get to
work.
What's
your go-to like load out
right now Uh other rail and the
Yeah, me too.
I'm going to have a ****
stroke.
I wait a minute and
Regroup on my mark.
Dude, I don't think I've ever
seen a looting in like a battle
royale game be as bad as this
**** video game. I'm not
going to lie. Though they don't
look at any other game and
realize, oh wait, if we do it
like this, like **** grabbing
people's loot after you kill em
is actually like the **** most
worst, like the worst thing
I've ever seen in my life. It's
like, why did they leave half
the **** out and have the ****
That was kind of like blackout,
right? Sort of like blackout.
Everything was in like ****
bang, bro. Yeah. It's just
literally just words. The UI is
confusing. **** like some guy
off of Netflix made it. It's
like you're trying too hard at
some point. He's going to
realize that you're trying too
hard. Our UAV is orbiting the
area. No pal. Wait, did they
grab the scene?
holding high-value equipment
have been located. Secure I
need them bands. I need them
bands.
And then I don't even know how
to **** navigate half these
buildings. Yeah, I know.
Especially this little ****
blue buildings that we're in,
bro. You want to try it? Oh,
yeah. There's an upstairs. We
gotta go out. I get time. They
gotta go back outside. One
thing down. Two to go. Two. I
do like this map though. Oh, I
like this map better than,
yeah, the master.
Give me your white chest, ****
I think isn't literally like
every other **** like bounty in
the same kind of like **** ****
You've secured all the Contact
complete. Crackers. How much
money have? So, whoop. How did
he do that? Jungle. Well, I
think marked the strongholds on
the map. Oh, this one's
unmarked. It just has on my
chest. Get in.
Yin.
We may stop right here, boys.
Hi, yourself again.
Yeah. Wait, you need a gun? We
want SMG yet. Here. Come here
Oh. Oh. Oh, right. SMG. I got a
car stop. Deploying portable
radar. No. It's not the one I
wanted to buy. Wait. You want
this one? I gotta cross them.
Moving here.
Bro, my I **** buy menu **** is
bugs. Like I, I click a buy at
at Post Office for you and it's
bought the No. Has that been
happening to you?
I have not experienced that one
yet.
Stop **** Dude.
Bomb disposal.
Jesus Christ. From Optimal. I
just **** slapped me. What the
****
Where the **** is the bomb?
Remember the bomb just like
blows up.
Oh my Christ.
roll. Okay, hold on. Let me
just grab one of the eight
ammunition boxes real quick.
Dropping ammo here.
I feel like scared running
around with this much ****
money, bro.
And this is where we sneak
away. They're they're very
occupied right now. They won't
realize how we're gone. How's
that guys still have two
plates? Come on. Wait, the
chopper's
Do they realize? Oh, four
realized. Uh oh. Four realized.
Look at this. He's coming. Oh,
I think they marked somebody.
Hey, he's coming. You forgot
about me. One, requesting recon
at this time. Copy. UAV is on
stage. Sorry. Recon online. Oh,
they got the GMC. Oh, ****
Out of the vehicle.
UAV is bingo fuel. RTV at this
time. Okay. Well, that works.
But I don't. I don't really
think you could do anything
with two roles, ADS.
I don't think you stand a
chance.
First revived kid here. No, I
can't even dare. Gas is inbound
Yeah.
Oh my god. He drives so scary.
Moving here.
Just hang out here with me.
That boy's jump.
Well, jump, jump, jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump. Dude, they're
not listening. It's on them.
It's **** got to you. UI, U
Using drill charge. Take it.
Hey, yo. Chill hackers. No,
dawg. You're going to get
beamed, baby. Strike near your
location. Wanna go near the
**** pimples?
but chill hack. **** murder
strike last for ****
thirty-five **** years.
Moving here. Oh my god. How
many more **** bombs bro? That
it? Alright, I'm coming in now.
Get ready. Okay. Have a we are
with each other. Big kiss on
lips. Lips. I like that.
Actually wall thing. No, no,
no, no. Wait, hold on, hold on,
hold on. We'll figure out.
Look, get ready, get ready,
ready? can't. You can't. You
can't have **** man. You like
that. You're lucky. You're
lucky. You're lucky little boy.
You're lucky you can't lick my
dick. I'll take you dude. Okay.
Dude, dude. He's **** five
years old, dude. That's ****
toxic. Aw.
On that one.
****
Only one. One more down. One,
two, one, two, one, two
Dude, they haven't been a trip.
Mine on the stairs and I just
jumped over.
Dude, you actually have pussies
in your **** games. What? We're
not lying about these **** try
hards, bro.
The **** like crazy try hard.
Bro. You just tell. I just came
too much, man. Okay, bro. Like,
I just can't grab the other
bag. Jesus Christ, bro. Oh, I
love that. It's a really cool
addition how you just can't.
Any ammo. Someone else's bag.
Enemy UAV active. Like a really
good addition that you just
can't grab someone else's bag.
I like how that one guy was
just literally just unloaded on
that one guy's body. You saw
the **** Burger King head ****
Yeah. beamed into. I don't
know. There's one guy by
himself right here. You see
this? Oh, wait. You might not
see this. Oh, so there's a bug.
Oh, okay. I might as well tell
you this. There's a bug where
if you grab the default scout
perk, enemy pops a UAV, you'll
see the the their UAV. on the
map. Pats, Pats are, that's
really bare. Give me them toes.
down. What the **** the
buzzers? Give me them toes.
This **** do it virtual. I was
like this. Do it virtual. I was
like this. Shooting underneath
the semi. Oh my god. Look the
glorious died. I can see his
toes from there. Oh god. I
guess he can. Give me them
toes. **** Say that. Drop
inbound. We have a zone. Oh
yeah. Come here. Come here. You
you you hit the glitch. Come
here.
What is this? Ping actually
work now? No. No. No. Of course
it does. Moving here. Moving
here. I don't think I have the
Scout person already my ****
No, it's on default. It's on
default. Okay
with this tour beside you. Oh
wait, I didn't grab the one in
the middle. Yeah, there's a
middle. The safe zone is far
from your location. Yeah, so so
click the top. His default
logo's at the top. Oh. Uh huh.
I'm going to click scope.
How many? We got 50 more people
up to? I only have three kills.
What am I doing? I got six.
It's like I never left.
Do we hear the whole game,
weren't we? Yeah, basically.
Oh, wait. The circle's split in
three
Oh, there's a UV ping right
here. Yup. Moving here. Propped
up for a second. Nope. Oh,
yeah. It's an advanced U
This is really cool. You should
have not told me about this.
Why? This is how you farm
kills. The pop UAV and they
realize, wait. Oh, they're
running down the hillside. I
see him. Yeah, I see him.
Moving here. Oh, I can't wait
to be. Oh, this is free
beamage. Oh, boys. I don't
know. I have to think they are
realizing that they're about to
die. Relocating the safe zone.
Sahara **** heat, bro. I can't
see them. Right there. Dude,
why is it so hot?
Moving. Yeah, I checked that.
Airstrike. Airstrike dead. UAV
in the area. See? Hostile UAV.
We got the UV.
Down there on.
Moving here.
I mean, like, what the **** are
they supposed to do? Copy that.
**** They present a pull but
they're following our foot. Oh,
yeah. Wait, they haven't got
the back one. Down one. You're
losing round. Finishes the map.
Dollars. Watch the fire. I
think our, I think our player,
I think our teammates are
gamers. I don't know.
really cool addition to the
game Well, it wouldn't make
sense to grab people's wife
racks, you know. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Mm hmm. Kind of a, kind
of a broken feature. Yeah,
like, what the hell, dude? Oh,
did you know about the, wait,
wait, there's another thing.
Okay, okay. So, when you hit
the dolphin dive, you know what
the dolphin dive boost? I don't
know how to do it. Why do you
just begin for the vault? Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You want to
be on something that's lower
and you want to hit space when
you Oh, **** And you could
shoot right when you do it by
the way. That's nerdy, dude.
What the ****
Also, you want to know another
glitch? Yeah, tell me. So, the
the UAV is out in the thing. It
only remarks on some buys. Um
you buy you buy, wait, come
here. Here come, you have $30,
000. I think you do it. Come
here. Yeah. So, see how the
UAV's out? Uh huh. Buy a plate.
Does does the one, did they
change the one? Is it a zero?
Okay, I have some kind as a
designer. There's only on
certain ones. But yeah, if you
just buy it and then it yeah.
Then I will change to one you
back out and you'll go back in
and you can buy the UV. Why the
**** can't I buy a **** bag in
this **** by the I mean,
requesting recon at this time.
Copy that. UAV online and all.
Oh my god. My marks. Jesus I
**** hate this little town.
**** hate it so much.
too, huh? That's actually just
**** **** Welcome to Raven.
Wait, nothing. Bingo fuel. RTV
at this time. This might be
bots right here. I think this
is bots. They really have not
moved. Yeah, they're AI.
Marking enemy.
**** a room. Drop down right
with me. Bro, right? When I was
going to beam his ****
What up to tell him a piece of
my mind? Okay, I'll come with
you.
Oh. And these **** think they
are, bro.
Okay. You literally need a ****
forehead. Oh.
Yeah, I'm kind of scared these
guys now. Oh, I'm. To the
ground. I was bought. Dude,
where the **** did you? what is
going on? Why is there a spot
bringing more bots? On the way.
Do you have a ammo? Yeah. Did
you? Yeah
Don't
go. Ammo here.
I could probably pop. I see
him. I see him. I see him. I
see him. Right here. What
Area is clear. What the ****
There's a guy like kicking
right here. Yeah, yeah, yes. Oh
wait, none.
Yeah, I see him.
Yeah, this stupid. That one in
that building? Ladder there?
Nice. Oh. Snapchat up there?
UAV is bingo fuel. RTV at this
time.
Oh, after that. Watch, watch,
watch, watch, watch. I got hold
on here. Watch out. We got the.
Friendly airstrike on the way.
Here you go. Alright
Dropping into the area. Watch
the skies. Uh. East too.
Choose. Choosing.
I don't know.
How many people put in that
**** What's going on? Look at
me. People are in the ****
bathroom. There's **** four
**** bathroom Bro, I look.
What? Wait, I picked up the
backpack.
Dropping some more. Alright. I
shot at some **** idiot in the
**** like. Bro, what? Yeah,
dude. Seventy-one. Seventy-one.
Shut up. Roof over there.
I'll show you seventy-one.
71 bullets, huh? How they
taste? I don't know. Those are
rude.
We can't get it higher.
It's not the plan. Nope. Nope.
Don't do that. Nope. That's on
it. Oh, get it back now.
Alright
Gas is closing.
Iso one.
You just join
but yeah. We can speak to one
of these guys. Ready? Three. Oh
yeah. Right here. Three. Enemy.
Two. One.
God is. Got us. Got us. That
one behind. Cracked him. I I'm
pushing. I have no ammo. Yeah.
Yo, rest me. Res me. Res me.
Res me. Res me. Let's do it.
You'll be alright. And then
after you rescue this, don't go
push, go push, go push. Oh,
**** There's two, there's two,
there's two, there's two,
there's two. One close on the
ridge, close on the ridge,
close on the ridge. You're
close left
Hold that angle. Hold that
angle. Recharge.
You have a snapshot too. Yeah,
but they don't work, bro.
You've got gas inbound. Safe
zone relocated.
Ammo here. Bro, I'm stuck on
the **** Only 10 are left.
Throwing stun grenade. I
finished one up there. I think
there's at least two.
the **** is he doing?
five. Oh, he's so bad. Oh my
god. One remain. They use this
There's noone else shoots
somewhere. Just lost it. I
can't believe that.
Oh, those **** people on the
**** roof just got **** innit.
The roll
is so dumb. It has no
damage drop off. Dude, there's
everyone just dying. It's so
crazy. A big poor guy that was
prone plating.
Jesus Christ.
Hoverback. Middle. Peace.
Dude, are you **** serious,
bro? It's **** pissed out of
two streams. What the ****
That's some **** **** **** man.
My piss just came out of two
streams and got ****
everywhere. Is that what
happened to you? He's ****
pissing and then there's two
streams. Why are you saying
this out loud, buddy? Dude,
it's **** annoying, bro. It
**** gets everywhere. Toilet
was not designed for this. Uh
What was the toilet designed
for? Pooping and and sitting
down and peeing.
I'm getting some crazy cracked
out computer like next week. I
spent, I spent 4. 5 on that
**** Oh, it sucks.
No, I can go Ryzen. Why because
the the **** forty ninety
wasn't compatible with the ****
CPU. I tried. It wouldn't let
me.
The same thing. And you get to
make your own playoff playlist.
Like a clicking MV and then I
try to put on the 4090 and just
didn't work so. Right. I just
wanted like an I nine. 13 K,
13, 700K or some **** I got it
through **** what's it called?
Have you heard of stints?
Stints builds?
Mm hmm. Yup. I have a, I have a
twelve. Wait, did you get the
thirteen 900 K? Uh here, hold
on. Let me find it. I've been
in the Email. Let's just build
it yourself. You would have
saved so much money. Cuz I'm a
**** pussy, bro. Plug it in.
Boom. Oh, really? Okay. Pretty
much, man. The only problem
like I would have is how to
plug in the the power button.
to plug in the power button.
Yeah, on top of the PC. And the
the lights and ****
Labor cost is only like 150
bucks so. Terrible. Well, you
got Why won't you get the K? I
don't know. Bro, you can't even
overflow. Like you're so
stupid.
Come here. I mean, that process
is really good but it is a ball
in the neck. If you have a
forty-ninety, that process is
not good enough. Handle of
4090. But we'll see. See what
happens. Oh, I know. I have
that process. Not, not that
one. I have the K version
because you know, I'm I'm not
cheap and I bought that.
Mine was seven. The enemy down.
No, I sent you fifty bucks.
It's like nothing.
which probably would definitely
you have so much money.
But look what gives so much
money.
Watch out. Wait till I'm
finished, bro.
Nobody doesn't make a moves.
There you go. Done.
here. Bams. Bams. Look at them
vans. Where's that? Robots in
there? You should have enough
there.
Dude, my god, my game is
going to glitch again. I'm just
going to buy him ammunition box
and. Bang, I buy a Fenneck.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure.
Okay, the money isn't showing
up for me. The money's not
showing up, Switch. I'm not
going to let me do it.
the **** money is hollowed out.
It's not letting me drop it.
Okay. But they're doing a
rebound by the UAV. Yeah, sure.
Targets are marked under attack
map. Guys behind us.
Pop it.
Pullover. This is the police.
You were under arrest.
What is that guy doing
Who's ready to blow up? Let me
know.
Enemy UAV overhead. No, this is
the police. All over. Game is
really **** intriguing
sometimes.
Jenny could cross over the
water with the Humvee You can.
Mm hmm. I'll see. should I grab
the sick cracker? No. I don't
need it.
Oh my god, it's the GMC Humvee.
****
Well, it's parked. Well, let's
park all the cars here. Let's
go get another one. Dude, I
swear it works, bro. I gotta,
wait, was it, was it the hobby?
I don't know what it was.
Humvee. Throw it out. Pull it
out.
Hey, you think we make it
through the water with the
truck? I'm D. What the ****